come on in family there we go
okay place your hand in the visor and
raise your right hand and then repeat
after me i deborah holland hi deborah
holland do solemnly swear
do solemnly swear that i will support
and defend that i will support and
defend
the constitution of the united states
constitution of the united states
against all enemies against all enemies
foreign and domestic foreign and
domestic
that i will bear true faith that i will
bear true faith and allegiance and
allegiance to the same
to the same that i take this obligation
freely that i take this obligation
freely without any mental reservation
without any mental reservation
or purpose of evasion or purpose of
evasion and that i will well and
faithfully
that i will well and faithfully
discharge the duties discharge the
duties
of the office upon which i am about to
enter on the office upon which i am
about to enter
so help me god so help me god
congratulations
congratulations congratulations
[Applause]
any journey is being made yet again
thank you here we are let's take a
picture
okay thank you
[Music]
you